bonjour Christopher Nolan bonjour c'est un
vrai plaisir de t'avoir ici aujourd'hui
es-tu prêt pour cette euh interview je suis
prêt ok donc tu peux voir l'écran
ici avec les Emojis si tu appuie sur le
buzzer ça arrêtera un emoji et nous'  Je
verrai la première question donc c'est un sablier
un chronomètre apparaîtra pendant 60 secondes
sur l'écran pendant ce temps je vais
vous donner une série de projections pour l'
année 2050 et l'idée est que vous
me donniez un mot ou quelques mots  peu importe ce
qui vous vient à l'esprit sur ce sujet,
d'accord,
commençons par le premier
transport en 2050. ou le vol de la
bombe nucléaire en 2050, les mêmes
salles de cinéma en 2015. plus grands et plus
magnifiques, jolis vos films en 2015.
ah, allez, ok, exploration spatiale  en 2015. Les
villes de Mars en 2050
aiment plus grand en 2015
.
ok, qu'en est-il de la
paix en 2050,
j'espère que
oui et qu'en est-il de la guerre en 2050, la
peur, bien, peut-être le dernier téléphone, les avions
en 2015. calme, bien, passons à la
question suivante, euh, pour que tu puisses appuyer sur le
buzzer
[Musique]
trois quarts de 16 à 25 ans  Les personnes âgées de
10 pays du Nord et du Sud
considèrent que l'avenir est effrayant.
Lamond ceci est un article publié dans
Lemont il y a environ deux ans. Trouvez-vous
l'avenir terrifiant ? Je trouve que l'avenir
dans mes moments les plus sombres est effrayant.
Je veux dire, j'ai grandi dans un  période de
concentration intense sur l'Armageddon nucléaire au
début des années 80 au Royaume-Uni, il y
avait beaucoup d'inquiétude dans la culture pop et
vous connaissez notre peur et notre relation
qui va et vient avec le temps et je
pense que nous vivons actuellement dans un monde
où  euh, c'est de retour dans l'
esprit des gens mais le truc à propos d'Oppenheimer,
son histoire, la raison pour laquelle j'ai fait le film
que j'ai fait, c'est euh, il a changé le
monde pour toujours, nous vivons dans un monde de
sa création et cela ne disparaîtra jamais
et  Je trouve cela effrayant quand on
regarde une chronologie croissante du
danger et de la menace, alors Oppenheim, bien sûr,
nous en parlerons a créé la
bombe nucléaire pour les États-Unis. Si
Oppenheimer n'avait pas créé la
bombe nucléaire, le monde se porterait-il mieux aujourd'hui ?
le monde serait certainement mieux
sans la menace des armes nucléaires. L'
une des choses intéressantes dans l'
histoire d'Oppenheimer sur les scientifiques
de l'époque et la façon dont ils ont interagi
avec les militaires sur ce programme est que pour
eux, l'énergie atomique était une simple réalité de
la vie.  c'était une découverte et donc il n'y avait
aucun moyen de la supprimer, il n'y avait aucun moyen
de révéler un secret, ils la considéraient comme une
information faisant partie de la nature et, en
ce sens, du pouvoir de l'atome, que ce soit les
objectifs pacifiques des gens et la
création d'énergie et  etc. ou toutes
les utilisations positives de la théorie quantique et de
la physique atomique, euh ou comme arme de
destruction massive pour eux, ces choses étaient
inévitables mais je pense que s'il y avait un
monde dans lequel
cela n'existait pas, ce serait
certainement mieux, mais de  Bien sûr, cela
lui dirait que l'invention de la
bombe à hydrogène a été décrite dans le film
par Benny. La sécurité, vous savez que son fils
est la bombe à hydrogène originale, donc pour
eux, comme je le dis, c'était un fait de la nature
et beaucoup de vos films populaires soulèvent  la
question d'une menace pour l'humanité, nous avons
vu Tenet Interstella Oppenheim bien
sûr qu'est-ce que cela dit de nous car ce
sont des films très populaires mais
peut-être aussi de vous, je pense qu'en tant que
cinéaste, nous recherchons les histoires les plus dramatiques
et donc dans les films populaires  culture euh dans
le langage du cinéma, que vous
remontiez aux films de James Bond des années 60
qui traitaient des tensions nucléaires pendant la
guerre froide, ce genre de choses, les cinéastes
recherchent la menace ultime pour notre
survie, la chose dont nous pouvons être les
plus effrayés.  et que le héros
pourrait nous sauver de ce que j'ai appris pour la première fois
à propos de l'histoire d'Oppenheimer, ce qui
m'a vraiment captivé, c'est qu'il y a eu
ce moment où lui et ses collègues
scientifiques du projet Manhattan
n'ont pas pu éliminer le potentiel d'une
réaction en chaîne de ce premier test qui aurait pu nous sauver.
détruire le monde entier et pourtant ils ont
appuyé sur le bouton et vous savez pour moi,
ce sont les enjeux les plus élevés dont j'ai jamais
entendu parler pour un film qui, vous savez, est une
situation très très dramatique ouais, nous pouvons
remettre les communautés en marche, vous pouvez appuyer
sur le buzzer  quand il veut
et c'est du pop corn mon équipe et moi nous sommes amusés à
demander à une IA de gbt de proposer le
titre et le synopsis d'un film dans ce
titre de Christopher Nolan on verra
ce que ça veut dire Nexus dans une
société futuriste contrôlée par l'
intelligence artificielle  c'est très vain ouais pour
une intelligence artificielle un
hacker rebelle découvre l'existence d'un
réseau secret qui relie tous
les esprits humains au Nexus alors qu'il plonge dans ce
monde virtuel complexe illusion
fusion de réalité mettant sa vie
en danger du sort de l'humanité qu'il doit trouver  le noyau
de la prochaine humanité sûre pour le
groupe de pertinence l'IA complète, nous disons
en anglais cordonniers parce que oui, c'est un
non-sens total, c'est comme s'il avait essayé de prendre
quelques éléments de quelques-uns de vos films et
avait fait une bouillie et juste une chose étrange est
sortie  ouais complètement, nous essayons aussi de
faire comme une affiche, ce qui était bien mais
ressemblait plus à une bande dessinée publiée sur
un vrai film,
vous sentez-vous inspiré par ceux-là, je ne suis pas
sûr euh pas massivement inspiré non euh à
part je veux dire AIS c'est c'est  un problème
que, euh, vous savez, en tant que membre de la guilde des écrivains,
mon syndicat est confronté en ce moment,
euh vous savez, et j'ai parlé à beaucoup de
chercheurs en IA ces jours-ci et et en ce
moment, ils voient ce moment comme leur
moment Oppenheimer auquel ils se réfèrent  c'est
parce qu'ils regardent son histoire et
disent, d'accord, nous sommes sur le point de libérer cette
technologie très puissante dans le monde
et qu'en est-il des
conséquences involontaires, que faisons-nous à ce sujet,
mais ce que je trouve encourageant concernant l'
utilisation de l'IA et le  le domaine artistique est que je
pense qu'ils seront des outils puissants,
mais en fin de compte, rien ne pourra remplacer la
créativité humaine et ces modèles et
la manière dont ils traitent
l'information, ils sont tous basés sur la
créativité humaine du passé, donc il y a de la
créativité humaine ici et aussi  c'est
quelque chose chez Oppenheimer, bien sûr, vous avez
choisi de ne pas utiliser CGI oui, y a-t-il un risque
que l'utilisation de technologies très avancées
telles que l'IA par exemple enlève la
substance des arts,
je ne pense pas, donc je pense que n'importe quel outil, je veux dire,
mon
choix de ne pas utiliser  L'infographie pour
représenter le test Trinity était vraiment un
choix mécanique, c'est un choix artistique
parce que je pense que l'infographie est
incroyablement sophistiquée et polyvalente
et qu'un travail extraordinaire a
été fait avec elle, elle a tendance à me sentir un
peu en sécurité, elle doit  Je joue davantage
dans le monde de l'animation, donc il est
difficile d'être menacé de leur part,
en particulier dans un film où le reste
du ton est très réaliste, très texturé.
Je pense que tout outil, qu'il soit généré par l'IA,
qu'il soit informatique ou autre,
est un autre outil pour les cinéastes.
créer avec et donc tant que nous avons
confiance en nos êtres humains
créant avec ces outils euh maintenant je pense
euh que le médium cinématographique continuera à
se développer de manière passionnante et intéressante et
dans le film Inception, le cerveau humain
reconstruit Wells presque parfaitement  dans
nos rêves au point où nous ne pouvons
plus distinguer bien sûr entre la
réalité et le rêve, pensez-vous que
lundi l'IA pourrait bientôt atteindre ce niveau de
créativité ou une capacité à dupliquer
les choses et à brouiller complètement les
frontières entre ce qui est réel et ce qui ne l'est
pas ?
Personnellement, je ne le pense pas, cela ne veut pas dire
que ce n'est pas un danger à considérer
ou une idée intéressante à considérer,
mais je pense que si vous regardez le domaine des
effets visuels, par exemple, lorsque j'ai
commencé à utiliser les effets visuels,
tout était une question de simulation.
à propos de l'idée que grâce à l'
infographie et au Ray Tracing, vous pourriez
parfaitement simuler un environnement et
finalement cela a atteint une limite et maintenant l'
approche est légèrement différente, l'
approche est plus photographique, ce sont plus des
textures photographiques qui les mappent sur des
formes en utilisant la complexité du monde
et de notre  possibilité de le capturer à l'
aide de caméras et ainsi vous voyez des zones
où, même s'il existe une
possibilité théorique de progression infinie dans
certains domaines, il y a une limite qui est
atteinte car le monde réel est par
définition infiniment complexe, le
monde réel n'a aucune limite et donc aucune
simulation numérique ou technologie qui
simule finalement, elle atteint toujours une
limitation particulière
euh, nous pouvons voir la question suivante sur laquelle vous pouvez
appuyer à nouveau dans le navigateur,
ok, ça s'arrête sur l'oiseau bleu donc c'est
probablement euh, les tweets derrière ma vie, c'est
comme un film de Christopher Nolan, je ne le fais pas.  Je ne
comprends pas vraiment ce qui se passe, que
lui dirais-tu ou ou où
je dirais n'essaye pas de le comprendre,
sens-le juste, c'est intéressant parce que je le vois.
J'ai vu des films parfois complexes
avec mes parents et c'est tellement frustrant
parce que 10  quelques minutes après le début
du film, ils disent attendre, je ne
comprends pas, je ne peux pas regarder ce qui
se passe maintenant parce que ce qui se passe
ici, comment voyez-vous cela, comment trouvez-vous
le bon équilibre entre
simplicité et complexité dans le film  Je
ne vois pas les films en termes d'équilibre
entre la simplicité et la complexité. Je pense que
c'est vraiment une question de mystère et de nos
attentes à l'égard des films,
vraiment toute ma vie, mais en réalité, depuis
les années 1950, j'ai été informé par la
télévision et les attentes de
la télévision et parfois c'est
malheureux, donc je  utiliser souvent des
structures non chronologiques, des structures non linéaires, ce
qui était quelque chose qui se
faisait beaucoup
à l'époque du silence, dans les premiers films parlants,
jusqu'à ce que la télévision
arrive, puis la télévision
impose en quelque sorte une approche plus linéaire et plus simple
à cause de  la façon dont nous
regardions la télévision à partir des années 1950,
puis lorsque le DVD vidéo domestique arrive et
maintenant en streaming, nous pouvons à nouveau être plus
aventureux parce que vous pouvez regarder
quelque chose, vous pouvez l'arrêter, vous pouvez rembobiner
quelque chose, jetez-y un œil pour que nous puissions
vous faire  connaître des récits plus denses, des
récits plus compliqués Mais en fin de compte,
le truc avec l'expérience dans une
salle de cinéma avec un public euh c'est que ça
devrait être une question de mystère euh tu ne
veux pas comprendre toute l'histoire
dès le début sinon
il n'y a rien à dévoiler et donc  vous
savez vraiment le talent du cinéaste,
le travail du cinéaste est d'essayer d'
être un peu en avance sur le public,
pas trop en avance, pas trop en retard
lorsque vous êtes derrière le public, le
public comprend les choses avant que
vous leur expliquiez  eux, le public est
très frustré d'une manière différente ouais
parce qu'ils sont comme si je savais que cela n'allait pas
arriver exactement une autre question je
pense qu'il reste deux questions, vous pouvez
appuyer sur le buzzer,
ok, c'est un autre minuteur, en gros, je vais
vous poser une série de questions  et l'
idée c'est de répondre oui non les commandes passent si
tu veux passer es-tu prêt allons-y
tu feras encore des films dans 10
ans oui pourrais-tu faire une émission télé un
jour non tu penses qu'il y a de la vie
ailleurs dans l'univers passe après
Batman veux-tu réaliser un autre
film de super-héros non, l'IA détruira-t-elle l'
humanité non non refuses-tu toujours d'
avoir un smartphone oui as-tu peur de la
mort
oui pourrais-tu avoir un compte tic tac
non comme si tu n'as pas de smartphone
c'est Interstellaire  votre film préféré dans
votre filmographie
aimeriez-vous faire un film Star Wars
est-ce que la musique est la chose la plus importante
dans un film non, non, c'est bien de manger
en regardant un film Oui, est-il acceptable de
regarder des films sur des smartphones ou des ordinateurs portables
oui oui oui
vous jouez à des jeux vidéo
peut-être qu'un dernier film est-ce qu'un film à gros budget
a plus de chances d'être un
bon film
non vous pouvez gagner plus de temps si vous voulez
répondre à cette question les relations sont
étrangement simples quand vous faites un film que
vous n'avez jamais fait  assez de temps et on
n'a jamais assez d'argent, quel que
soit le budget et donc je pense vraiment que
le budget n'a pas vraiment d'importance, c'est
là que ça devient intéressant, c'est l'
interaction du sujet avec
le budget, vous savez, mon premier film était un
film intitulé suite à ça  J'ai tourné avec
des amis, vous savez, nous travaillions tous à temps
plein, nous tournions un jour par
semaine le week-end, nous ne dépensions pas d'argent
pour le film,
mais j'ai écrit le scénario en sachant que c'est
ainsi que nous allions le faire, donc le manque
de  le budget et le sujet étaient
synchronisés et je pense que tant que vous pouvez
maintenir cet équilibre, je pense que vos
chances de réaliser un bon film sont absolument
égales quel que soit le niveau auquel vous travaillez,
donc je suppose que même comme un film comme
Oppenheimer l'était peut-être.  impossible pour
vous de le faire comme lorsque vous avez commencé
exactement des films et maintenant bien sûr vous
avez besoin d'une certaine quantité de ressources pour
nous parler du sujet d'une manière particulière euh je veux
dire, je pense que vous pouvez aborder n'importe quel
sujet de différentes manières,
certaines le feraient  être plus petits, certains seraient
plus grands, ce que vous devez décider en tant que
cinéaste : euh, y a-t-il toujours une petite
histoire ou pas certainement avec Inception ? Je
me souviens que c'était un film sur lequel j'avais travaillé pendant de
nombreuses années et que je n'avais aucun moyen d'obtenir un gros
budget.  pour cela et donc j'ai continué à essayer de
voir s'il y avait un projet plus petit
et cela ne fonctionnerait jamais de cette
façon pour moi et donc j'ai attendu jusqu'à ce que je puisse
obtenir le bon budget pour cela,
donc c'est vraiment une question d'histoire  et sur
la portée de l'approche que vous souhaitez
adopter, mais ce que vous ne
voulez pas faire, c'est commencer à faire un film avec
un mauvais budget pour le sujet.
Une dernière question, je pense que nous avons, vous
pouvez appuyer sur le  une autre une dernière fois
[Musique]
donc derrière cet Emoji il y aura une vidéo il y a
une interview d'Oppenheimer à
la télévision française le 4 mai 1962. à cette
époque il avait déjà construit bien sûr la
bombe nucléaire pour les Etats-Unis il
avait déjà atterri  sur Hiroshima et
Nagazaki tuant des centaines de milliers
de personnes et il appelait maintenant au
contrôle international des armes nucléaires
comme vous le savez, alors les journalistes ici ichien
Lalu lui ont posé une question sur le sort
de l'humanité et vous pouvez voir que sa
réponse est
serbe perçue
ici
devrait  ça ne nous balaye pas
mesure optimiste ouais que
voyez-vous ici à Oppenheimer
Je vois un homme qui est toujours extrêmement
prudent à propos de tout ce qu'il dit après
1945 après les bombardements d'Hiroshima
Nagasaki, il a fait très très attention à
ne jamais s'excuser et à assumer une
responsabilité personnelle pour ce  s'est produit
mais les actions qu'il a entreprises et c'est l'une
des raisons pour lesquelles je voulais
raconter l'histoire, euh les actions sont celles de
quelqu'un avec un sens très très
développé de responsabilité et de
honte et donc la façon dont il a
répondu à beaucoup de ces questions  plus tard
dans la vie, ils sont très très
prudents et je pense que c'est une
expression très éloquente de oui, c'est
difficile une fois que l'on approfondit vraiment la
question de la bombe atomique, comment elle est
devenue ce qu'elle est, où elle va à partir de là,
elle est  très difficile d'être optimiste,
mais le fait que vous sachiez qu'il
veut toujours garder espoir, je pense, est
révélateur de qui il était en tant que personne et
aussi de la façon dont il ressentait le besoin de
communiquer avec les gens, car si vous
dites simplement aux gens que le ciel nous tombe sur la tête
tout le temps qu'ils arrêtent d'écouter et
dans le film bien sûr dans la vraie vie
parce que bien sûr, sur la base de l'
histoire vraie, les scientifiques envisagent la
possibilité que la bombe détruise toute
l'humanité. Heimer pense que
le risque est proche de zéro et pourtant il  continue
bien sûr le test est-ce que c'est du courage est-ce de la
folie comment définiriez-vous cette
action
je pense qu'il est très difficile d'exploiter
la façon dont ces scientifiques ont vu
le contexte j'étais bien sûr le contexte
est très important ils ont estimé que c'était
quelque chose qui devait absolument
se produire
et leur évaluation du risque est
particulièrement
subjective sur le plan statistique. Vous savez, ce
sont des scientifiques et ils voient le risque d'une
manière très particulière. Je pense que pour la plupart d'entre
nous, l'ampleur
des conséquences l'
emporte sur
la petitesse du risque, mais je  Je pense
que les
esprits plus scientifiques et logiques n'ont
pas vu l'ampleur des conséquences comme
affectant la probabilité statistique
du risque. Je pense que nous tous, en tant que
non-scientifiques, comprenons le fait que si vous appuyez sur
ce bouton, vous pourriez détruire le
monde entier, même si le risque est minime.  nous, nous n'appuierions pas sur
le bouton, mais je pense que pour
les scientifiques, l'ampleur des
conséquences n'est pas la question, le fait
est qu'ils ont fait leurs calculs qui ont
montré qu'il est
très très improbable qu'appuyer sur ce
bouton détruirait le monde, donc  ils vont de
l'avant et ils le poussent ouais sur puissant
c'était je suis content que celui-ci ne soit pas
suffisant ouais et bien sûr pour que
tout le monde ait le contexte dans ce film
et soit bien sûr des nazis et le risque qu'ils
aient la bombe nucléaire et cela peut  utilisez-
le donc il y a bien sûr ce
monde politique, je veux dire, ce qui est
vraiment intéressant pour moi dans l'
histoire, je n'avais aucun intérêt à faire un film
sur des scientifiques qui étaient deux stupides pour
se rendre compte que s'ils construisaient cette chose,
ils étaient terribles, des choses arriveraient  c'étaient des
gens très très brillants
qui étaient bien conscients
du potentiel de ce qu'ils faisaient
mais ils étaient dans une situation où ils
savaient que les Allemands avaient divisé l'atome,
ils savaient qu'ils essayaient de fabriquer
une bombe nucléaire et euh  vous savez, gagner la
guerre de cette façon et ils ont donc senti qu'ils n'avaient
absolument pas le choix et c'est ce qui
rend cette histoire si convaincante et nous
parlions de l'IA il y a quelques minutes
et bien sûr de cette question de repousser
les limites, devrions-nous toujours
donner la priorité au progrès de  La science et le fait de
repousser les limites de tout le
reste, ce tuyau risque peut-être de savoir comment
trouver le bien par rapport à une sorte d'
équilibre. Je veux dire, je pense que vous voyez
des scientifiques parfois perdus dans la
théorie pure de ce qu'ils font et pas
nécessairement conscients.  des implications,
mais je pense aussi qu'il est réducteur et
simpliste de dire bien avant que les scientifiques ne
réalisent des progrès, nous devons planifier la façon dont
nous allons y faire face. Vous voyez cela dans mon
travail en ce moment, vous savez, dans le
secteur du cinéma, les gens sont très inquiets pour
Ai et  les applications
et ils veulent une protection contre cela, mais
la réalité est que jusqu'à ce que ces choses
progressent. Il est difficile de savoir ce qui
doit être contrôlé et je pense que
beaucoup de progrès scientifiques sont comme
ça jusqu'à ce que nous voyions le potentiel jusqu'à ce qu'il
commence à  Il faut se rendre compte qu'il est très
difficile pour le reste de la société de
légiférer pour juger et c'est là que le
vrai danger vient de ce qu'Oppenheimer
considérait comme le vrai danger et je pense qu'il
avait raison, c'était le secret, ils avaient dû
développer le projet Manhattan dans un
secret intense mais  ils l'ont combattu, les
scientifiques l'ont combattu à chaque
étape parce qu'ils croyaient que
la connaissance devait être partagée, elle devait être
ouverte et de cette façon, les dangers
et les avantages pourraient être partagés par
tous et gérés par tous et  Je
pense qu'appliqué à
la plupart des exemples de ce que vous demandez
à propos de ce qu'il appelle la franchise, vous
savez que l'ouverture est en fait essentielle,
c'est aussi quelque chose que nous voyons dans le film,
il cherche la paix et cela rend le
thème de l'objectif paradoxal avec le
histoire que nous connaissons d'Oppenheimer mais il
prétend qu'il veut la paix et en
même temps bien sûr, construire cela, ce qui
peut être une menace est une menace bien sûr
et donc c'est toute une éthique et bien il a été l'
une des premières personnes à qui il n'a pas fait
référence  à cela comme une destruction mutuelle assurée,
mais il a été l'une des premières
personnes ici, Niels Boar, à commencer à
explorer et à articuler l'idée qu'avec
des armes si puissantes, le type de
guerre que nous avions vu pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale et la
Première Guerre mondiale devient impraticable et
impensable et  Il y a un argument : une
façon de voir la situation dans le
monde d'aujourd'hui est qu'il a eu raison
jusqu'à présent.
Euh, je ne sais pas, à l'époque, il n'y avait pas de
réponses faciles aux questions
que son histoire soulève. Je pense que le film
C'était incroyable d'aborder ces questions sur lesquelles
je veux lire la biographie maintenant
et continuer à en apprendre davantage sur lui.
Merci beaucoup Christopher Nolan pour
vous remercier d'avoir pris le temps aujourd'hui et
ouais, amusez-vous à Paris aujourd'hui, merci, merci
beaucoup, merci.  tu merci